our next story also festive Christmas
ornaments they carry history with them a
family Milestone a memory and that is
especially true for the annual White
House Christmas ornament which honors
past presidents typically in each given
year this year's version a gingerbread
White House is inspired by Richard
Nixon's presidency Ed O'Keefe looks
inside this long holiday tradition and
the family business that creates every
single ornament
just like some people always make sure
to get the gas station toy truck
or the Holiday Barbie and the warmth of
holiday cheer fills us with joy many
families had the White House ornament to
their holiday wish list each year I got
one for myself I got one from my mom
even the first families display them at
1600 Pennsylvania Avenue
but the ornament gets its start about
400 miles away at Kmart in Lincoln Rhode
Island here the ornament is as much a
Christmas tradition as the tree itself
it's really like we're in Santa's
Workshop it really is it's it's
um it's it's working it's craftsmanship
Dave Marquis and David Beaupre run the
company that's been making the ornament
since its Inception in 1981. it's been
so part of our DNA for so long 42 years
we've been running this annual ornament
program so it's part of who we are
David's father Richard Beaupre a chemist
and inventor started the metal etching
business more than four decades ago not
long after the opportunity of a lifetime
first lady Nancy Reagan wanted to make a
White House Christmas ornament as a
keepsake
Kmart took on the task collaborating
with the White House historical
Association chemmart has worked through
42 ornaments usually honoring presidents
but occasionally marking other important
moments in White House history these
ornaments allow us to unpack that
history year by year and we tell
something about that presidency not
politics or policy it's about educating
the public and it's about restoring the
house restoration paid for from proceeds
from an ornament that's completely hand
assembled and American made as you see
this big push to bring it all back into
the United States yes you guys that
never left no never will it's a culture
David's dad built and that continues
today with longtime employees at the
family business including Kim Fife she's
been with chemmart since 1986 and now
leads the design team that's the fun
thing is finding something that people
don't know Kim does most of her own
research seeking out lesser-known
stories about presidents and Christmas
she visits Presidential Library areas
and historic sites to scour old records
photographs and books so in essence
you're one of the foremost experts on
White House Christmas history
if I would say that but
right this year the team settled on a
gingerbread White House in tribute to
Pat Nixon the first first lady to
display the now iconic gingerbread house
as part of the White House decorations
once the design is confirmed workers
start carefully building handmade
Treasures piece by piece in essence
you're kind of making Christmas for
everybody yes I guess they give you a
sense of Pride every time you see it
that every single help and do that every
single day Stuart McLaurin is president
of the White House historical
Association a nonpartisan privately
funded group that helps restore and
preserve the famous address they try to
teach presidential history through each
ornament President Eisenhower was the
first American President to use a
helicopter for presidential travel and
this is a replica of the model of his
helicopter the first year they sold only
a few thousand ornaments but that number
has now ballooned to hundreds of
thousands it's a labor of love really
for those of us who invest in this and
try to come up with something unique and
creative this year they added scent of
gingerbread infused into the Nixon
recipe included with the ornament
gingerbread it's those kinds of details
that had people Ginger snapping them up
at the National Christmas Tree it's the
first one I've had but I'm sure I'll
start a little collection
always around the country collecting
White House holiday keepsakes
while doing their part to keep the house
intact and passing along this little
labor of love to those they love
Merry Christmas
next year's design honors former
President Gerald Ford it will be
unveiled on President's Day in February
at the Gerald Ford library and that's
one next year's ornament goes on sale
here's another look at this year's it
does indeed smell like gingerbread it's
the actual it's the gingerbread recipe
so you get a little scent you get a
little ornament all the proceeds most of
the proceeds go to help again restore
the home none of it goes to presidents
themselves but to restoring the White
House of course America's Home Nate so
if you're looking for a last minute gift
you want to plan ahead to next year
the White House ornament's an option you
hang it from the car window that's right
and I love I just love how you gingerly
walk through every story well done my
brother